I should say first of all this has
played out over many months all around
the world but we still don't know
exactly what's in this deal if people
are talking about it but we don't know
the contents entirely that's exactly
right this has been done as you would
expect quietly and within the four walls
of the conference rooms of the
negotiating room so we don't know
exactly would say we have some idea
because a lot of it has been discussed
in general terms so bearing that in mind
and I don't mean to characterize these
as winners and losers perhaps gainers
and losers let's start with those who
stand to win or gain from this
particular deal internationally who
stands best again what if the United
States gains a lot because we've been
asking for other countries to have
higher environmental standards higher
workplace standards higher standards for
intellectual property protection we want
state enterprises to be able to assume
the same responsibilities for fair
competition as private sector companies
so that we have a level playing field
between our private companies and state
enterprise companies around the world so
those are the gainers in agriculture
we're getting some good opportunities
that we haven't had before so I think
the United States does quite well we
obviously have to give to get and you
have to make concessions as every
country has done but I think it's good
for the United States in a broad sense
but then again we don't know the details
so it's hard to make a final judgment
but on the base of what I've seen it
looks like we're doing quite well so
those who have sounded the clarion
against this who've said it's going to
be harmful our pharmaceutical companies
agriculture interests as well we had
President Obama going to the AG
department today to talk to farming
interests there bearing in mind what we
know we don't know do they have a case
there do they stand to lose with this
deal certain groups didn't get as much
as they want and that's the nature of a
negotiation the pharmaceutical industry
wanted more on certain types of very
high quality drugs
they didn't get as much patent
protection or as long as they wanted
things of that nature farm farmers
perhaps wanted to get more in certain
markets the auto industry didn't get as
much as they wanted didn't want to give
up quite as much as it did but by and
large you have to really look at this
from where we started out to where we
are now and even though it's not perfect
even though certain groups didn't get
what they wanted it seems to be positive
and we should reserve our judgment or
puzzles me that there are groups of
people who criticize this and say we
don't have enough information it's not
transparent at the same time they
denounce the agreement and say it's
unacceptable it's hard to have it both
ways and I think that I can see that I
don't have all the details but from what
I hear it sounds like we've gotten a
considerable amount Mike Froman has been
negotiating is a very able negotiator
and I have a lot of confidence in him